ja ich habe mich heute über aufgeregt
über die bayern denn von nächster woche
an nach den herbstferien gilt in bayern
die den basken pflicht für kinder in den
schulen gleich nach ende der bayerischen
herbstferien grund sind die steigenden
instanz werte die sind mal megamäßig
hoch in manchen landkreisen 400 manchmal
500 vor allen dingen hier an der grenze
zu ziehen dass der start der
handlungsfähigkeit beweisen muss das ist
klar nach dem motto wir wissen auch
nicht mehr weiter aber masten pflicht
für kinder das geht immer was mich
besonders ärgert es vor kurzem ist diese
masken pflicht ausgesetzt die aufgehoben
worden nach den sommerferien war das ein
paar wochen später und ein paar wochen
vor der bundestagswahl die
bundestagswahl ist nun gelaufen
gegen diese aus wie erhofft und da sagt
man masken pflicht muss wieder sein und
obwohl kinder unter zwölf bis zu dreimal
in der woche getestet werden obwohl
kinder über zwölf ihre impfung machen
können zu impfen berechtigt sind und
obwohl bayerns ministerpräsident markus
söder erst kürzlich in der welt am
sonntag gesagt hat ich zitiere da ist
wenn der bundestag die epidemische lage
nicht mehr verlängert dann bedeutet das
wohl das ende aller sicherheitsauflagen
dann hätten wir so markus müllsünder
wörtlich ende november indirekt den
freedom day von freedom ist zumindest an
bayerns schulen nicht zu sehen
stattdessen die masken pflegekinder
diejenigen die am meisten darunter
leiden
frei nach herbert grönemeyer möchte ich
sagen den handelnden politikern geht den
king gibt den kindern das kommando denn
wenigstens sie wissen was sie tun
das ist ein wichtiger punkt den kindern
das kommando geben ich bin so
zwiegespalten was die frage angeht was
du völlig richtig gesagt hast die kinder
über zwölf jahre die sich impfen lassen
können bei dem bin ich doch eher dafür
die massen vielleicht auch verein zu
lassen weil man dort tatsächlich auf 3g
durchsetzen kann im zweifel ich finde es
aber darunter sehr schwierig nur wenn
man eine flächendeckende testung der
schüler sicherstellt und da kein ja aus
thüringen berichten haben noch immer
keine protesten vor den ferien an den
schulen gehabt als einziges bundesland
kann man nicht gewährleisten dass das
wegfallen der maske irgendwie die
inzidenz nicht weiter steigen lassen die
inzidenz ist ja nun mal bei den fünften
kindern so unwahrscheinlich hoch und das
ist ja auch der überträger ich muss aber
auch sagen ich merke bei mir an der uni
auf der anderen seite wir sind alle 3g
wir müssen 3g sein sonst dürfen das
universitätsgebäude nicht rückten
betreten aber sitzen trotzdem mit maske
irgendwie in der vorlesung und das ist
schwierig weil auf der einen seite ich
mich ja okay ist es schon richtig aber
auf der anderen seite denken aber ich
habe doch nachgewiesen dass ich habe so
ungefähr und deswegen glaube ich bei dem
über 12 jährigen schon ja wenn man
nachweisen kann geimpft gewesen getestet
bei den unter zwölfjährigen bin ich da
er auch wenn das vor allem die kleineren
sind das ist ja das tragische daran dass
die man die noch weiterhin beibehält
solange man die texte vielleicht
entdecken sicherstellen kann ich aber
jetzt hat sich doch gerade erst der
stiko chef geäußert er möchte keine
impfempfehlung für kinder unter zwölf
jahren aussprechen und hat dann nebenbei
ein bisschen normaler gesagt ja wenn man
sich die statistiken anschaut tragen den
nicht maß gewicht epidemischen
verbreitung weil also von dem her sehe
ich nicht wie die jetzt die antreiber
sein sollen bei den incidence werten und
warum zwingen wir sie dann maske zu
tragen und sie haben fast ich werde
verläuft ist natürlich richtig aber sie
bringt es mit nach hause also wir hatten
in gotha eine stadt in thüringen hatten
wir eine schule wo von 900 schüler und
401 quarantäne gegangen sind und
daraufhin die instanz im gesamten im
gesamten landkreis sogar so krass
angestiegen sind weil die kinder bringt
es mit nach hause es ist ja doch de
facto so und wir haben nun mal gerade so
viele impft projekt durchbrüche klar wir
reden über niedrigere verläufe und aber
muss er trotzdem irgendwie bedenken wir
stecken noch in der pandemie drin also
jetzt zum beispiel die schule von meinen
nichten da wird jeden tag getestet also
ist es möglich jeden jeden jeden tag mit
einem test in die schule gehen und dass
man trotzdem maske zahlen die ganze zeit
alle 20 minuten wird gelüftet das ist
teilweise super kalt die müssen die
jacken anziehen es wird sogar die eltern
diskutieren gerade sogar darüber welches
ob andere kinder auch mal am fenster
sitzen damit andere kinder auch mal
zitieren
das geht einfach nicht also die kinder
sind die leidtragenden in der panama
haben keine sternfahrer sind keine
inflationstreiber um dass man diese
kinder gerade sozial isoliert und
schikaniert ich meine nichte ist 8
diesen zweiten kasse also was soll das
das macht mich wirklich richtig wir
gehen also man muss ja auch sehen dass
die rahmenbedingungen sicher auch zum
teil verändert haben also in nrw es ist
also ab dienstag sind die schüler von
mund- und nasenschutz am sitzplatz
befreien das ist natürlich sehr gut ganz
gut das ist ja auch verrückt die beiden
größten bundesländern völlig
antizyklisch
das wollte ich das wollte ich nur sagen
dass man sich mit den rahmenbedingungen
wenn man sich zum beispiel in nrw die
impfquote bei den lehrern anschaut
inzwischen über 90 prozent ich meine das
sind ja das sind ja parameter die man
nicht ignorieren darf und auch die
impfquote bei den kindern bei den
schülern ab 12 das nimmt ja alles in der
richtigen geht hier in die richtige
richtung das heißt da kann man natürlich
schon wege gehen um sage ich mal einfach
zur normalität zurückzukehren
selbstverständlich gibt es die
diskussion in nrw auch in einer wm
landtag vor allem aber aus meiner sicht
ist diese entscheidung in einer welt
völlig richtig und wie brauchen diese
normalität endlich und zu hause hat sich
natürlich auch viel verändert die
großeltern die er immer herhalten muss
eine frühe dafür dass man sagte die
kinder müssen die maske tragen damit sie
sich nicht anstecken die sind doch auch
geimpft mittlerweilen das heißt also
dieser vorwurf die kinder bringt es nach
hause und dann ist oder ob die toten das
wird im kleinen aber noch mal leid tun
denn der ist ja auch völlig irrelevant
geworden also insofern gibt es da alles
argumente schon ziemlich daneben ich bin
halt dass man am ende auf die kinder
einen ähnlichen maßstab anderen legen
muss wenn man das der wachsenden
großveranstaltungen oder in räumen macht
wir dürfen die maske dann ablegen wenn
drei gilt und das muss auch für die
schulen gelten meines erachtens ich
glaube aber das finde ich ganz
interessant dass du sagst beiden nichten
ist jeden tag einen test also wir
kriegen jetzt irgendwie für zwei wochen
test und da wird zweimal die woche
getestet an allen schülern also das ist
so krasse unterschiede allein dass die
testungen an schulen angeht dann können
wir aber auch zu unterschiedlichen
regelungen eben am ende komme ich weiß
nicht wer in nrw aussieht also ich finde
ich mit dem punkt
beeindruckende bemerkenswert das was
vorhin auch gesagt wird dass gerade nrw
und bayern so unterschiedliche wege
gehen also jemand der nicht tief in
diesem politischen betrieb drin ist und
von außen einfach nur als normalbürger
dieser entwicklung vergleicht was soll
denn noch glauben der kanton
kopfschüttel die einen
die anderen sagen nur noch mehr
freiheit für alle also das ist macht
alles so in der art ist es ein großes
vermittlungsproblem noch mal zurück zu
der frage der testung auch hier vermisse
ich tatsächlich auch wenn die länder
zuständig sind aber ein übergreifendes
koordiniertes verhalten ich weiß das ist
ländersache trotzdem bei einer so
wichtigen frage die so viele menschen so
viele kinder angeht wenn man sich doch
wenn ich das mal so etwas macht wir
setzen uns sagen wir versuchen test
überall durch sind wir mindestens
dreimal pro woche die lüfter die sg da
sind damit kinder eben nicht nur da das
ist die frage gibt wer sitzt am fenster
und frieren muss man damit hier wirklich
dann auch der regelung herbeigeführt
werden kann die bestand hat und vor
allen dingen bisschen seit zwei jahren
mittlerweile schon fast jahre pandemie
werden kann doch nicht die antwort sein
belassen die kinder frieren das finde
ich dass ich irgendwann müssen sehen
lüften ist wichtig und so weiter aber
natürlich finde ich echt krass da bin
ich wieder bei klatschen und kniebeugen
machen im kopf jetzt halt auch so das
wegbleiben der vernunft oder also es
gibt diese gewisse regelung eines
fenster muss alle 20 minuten aufgemacht
werden die kinder müssen maske schaden
da hat man ja immer wieder und anstatt
dass die wähler sich sagen nun ja
vielleicht können wir mal eine ausnahme
machen vielleicht das ist sehr kalt
lassen wie jetzt wenn ein mann hält sich
wirklich in gent bei den bei den kindern
an diese teilweise absurden regelungen
das ist auch so das schlechteste was
man würde
also für bayern habe ich früher die
zumindest die korona politik immer so
gedeutet dass auch was mit dem internen
wettbewerb innerhalb der union zu tun
hat als darstellt noch da aber
selbstverständlich sondern
bundestagskollege aber oft so dachte ich
das hat er was damit zu tun aber
offensichtlich setze ich das sofort
wenn ich insofern aber ganz
grundsätzlich spannend die gesamte frage
nach dem testen weil
in mir fällt das immer wieder auf dass
das auch in der elternschaft so eine
spaltung gibt was das angeht und wir
hatten neulich ein ganz krassen fall was
testen geimpft seinen nicht schulen
angeht hat eine lehrerin nachgefragt
würdet ihr euch den impfen das hat sie
nur nach der fraglichen schöner nichts
aufgeschrieben oder so sondern es gab
eine menge diskussionen darüber gab es
eltern die darauf in unserem
datenschützer geschrieben haben wenn sie
den vielleicht ein bisschen außerdem
berichterstattung kenne so ober
datenschützer der immer wieder alles
doch der jetzt gegen die lehrerin wegen
datenschutzkonformität ermittelt weil
sie nun erfragt hat man sich also es
gibt ja so viele irre zustände in der
schule im rahmen der panini also ich
komme nicht ich komme ganz generell
nicht mehr aus dem kopf schüttelt man
aus den härtesten fundamentalismus
debatten
soll das thema ist emotional besetzt
wahnsinnig emotional besetzt ich will
jetzt nicht den fall von joshua kimmig
hierauf machen aber da und bei der
debatte kommt man auch sehen dass die
fakten eher zweitrangig waren sondern
enorme emotionen in unterschiedlichen
richtungen diesbezüglich existiert ein
bemerkenswert